[Music]
this is the story of Emiliano Salah a
footballer from baurel Argentina days
away from achieving his dream of playing
in the Premier League
his death has placed an intense focus on
the often tawdry business of
professional football a tragedy
seemingly so avoidable with so many
unanswered questions sallet was born in
the village of Clue Lu home to more cows
than people in October 1990 his mother
Mercedes and father a CEO splits when he
was young together with sister Romina
and brother Dario they moved to nearby
Progreso where Salas spent many happy
days joking around and having barbecues
with a close-knit group of friends who
remained his support system until the
end
Madras Anya's Agra rondônia same brand
of condom Osaka mayor Sarah South Molton
Molteni was Emiliano his oldest and
closest childhood friend he helped carry
his coffin Vogel commune so in the
summers are gonna say tanto como el
football for the primera momento que con
su mo in Vienna so this is why you came
to play when you were kids
ya gotta win the word on the pessoa
mucho tiempo el pasado a gaseous a car
event equator is America trained Yoona
in chambray food one of edenia
yellow food lnu they were inseparable
camping out in the garden of a friend's
house during the long hot summer months
the gemba Samuel Aquila timbren la
mañana y la gomera chelicerata Sevilla
Morini soulfood Wally pursue a Mohammad
are gonna getcha chocolate on a homicide
us yo mosa la casa
uno sa llamo wonderful yah
you see [ __ ] there Yoshio Giordano who
the first time Emiliano
moved away from home he was just 15
playing in Europe he briefly returned to
Argentina before moving to France making
his professional debut for Bordeaux in
February 2012 at first he struggled to
find a place in the first team farmed
out on loan to smaller clubs across
France learning the languages he went
fault it was FC non where he really hits
his stride in his final season he was
among the top scorers in Ligue 1
surpassing the likes of World Cup winner
killing and ba pay and Brazilian Neymar
despite being paid 50,000 pounds a month
Salah lived modestly in this rented
house in Kaka fou a small town 15
minutes drive from Nantes in the
vineyards over the road where Muscadet
wine is produced he walked his black
Labrador Nala a creature of habit
Salo prayed in the local church before
every game and I saw him praying just
here it was very it was praying very
very deeply it was quite impressive
we could feel his faith in fact and it's
more other whether it was just with him
beside him it was just before match at
the beginning of the negotiations about
his transfer and I could feel as if it
was quite nervous quite anxious about
this these changes I recognized him
because I'm a fan of FC not I've seen on
fan and so I went to him and I blessed
him the Saturday before he died salad
visited jean-philippe roussel a barber
who became a friend after cutting his
hair every three weeks for four years
presenting him with the number 9 shirt
he wore on the pitch Dobis chameleon we
had to over you pee too
I know man welcome to industry eleven
Solano's casita de travail
sulabha
we know the focus to VEISHEA what a
Celica dobutamine dealer who named the
vapor could be a few pieces a key Kira's
autism so that you do yes he even
invited family and friends from
Progresso to visit him in France when el
año pasado la basílica primero de de de
Nantes a su casa de una semana con el
men Dennis a maneuver a lien not Remo
mucho para ver de ávila Hawaii boo eco
no Cheryl Carina latina hand
[Music]
lo que fuera say so Mundi Ali Salim OC
siempre en el initiative a la cámara de
serranos
en Argentina NASA gonna say no solder
another dimension amo pero tienen quando
sorry mo Sacramento a la una vez de la
hindi circa Oliviana photo repeats
awesome ND the suburban streets of caca
foo which emiliano sala loved a far
removed from the glitz and excess of the
modern-day Premier League but the deal
which took him from here in western
France to South Wales is a window into
the often murky world of football
transfers with its agents its middlemen
and the huge sums of money at stake
Salle's long-term agent Meza and IA
British football agent Willie McKay and
his son Mark and France based agents
Bubba drama and Barker ISA no-go were
all in line for a payouts it is clear
why and IA who is supported Salas family
in the wake of the tragedy stood to
benefit it's not obvious exactly why
four individuals were needed to complete
the deal Emiliano initially didn't even
want to go to Cardiff but behind the
scenes the McKay's had been given a
mandate to find a buyer for him in the
Premier League
Willie sent an email to Saleh on January
the 6th seen by Sky News admitting
trying to strum up interest in the
striker
he wrote we are not interested in
looking after your personal interests
finance holidays babysitting is not our
market we do transfers in reality if
you're not a footballer these people
don't care about you they only care
about money because that's all we care
about
Cardiff have been told you don't want to
go there and that's probably our fault
it was also put in the media about all
the clubs wanting you West Ham Everton
etc to try create an interest in you
that's what we do it's this email which
it's understood Cardiff and owner
Vincent tan and now using as the partial
basis for withholding the 15 million
pound transfer fees and once they claim
Makai tricked them by artificially
increasing the price through lying about
the level of interest in truth this sort
of manipulate
is not uncommon in professional football
transfers without the tragedy which
followed the murky details of this deal
would almost certainly never come to
light when you start to look into this
transfer then you see a lot of people
talking about money about you know
intermediaries agents people who mingle
there and you don't really know what
their role is and what they are really
bringing to this but they make a lot of
money out of this
so yeah the more you look into the
details of the transfer the more
uncomfortable and uneasy you get about
but modern football diamond I mean it
attendance it's not only with seller
sallet signed for Cardiff on January the
18th alongside chief executive can chew
at 15 million pounds he was the club's
record transfer it was hoped he could
make his debut against Newcastle the
next day but the deal didn't go through
in time setting in motion the events
which led to the 28 year olds death he
hadn't spent much time in Cardiff but
salla struck up a friendship with makai
son Jack the striker for the club who
spoke French from eight years living in
Monaco the Mackay family offered to
arrange a private flight to Nantes they
claimed as a favor so Sala could return
for the weekend after seeing friends and
putting his affairs in order in France
he began the journey back to Wales
sallet dropped his dog Nala at the
kennels at 5 p.m. the plan had been
eventually for her to join him in
Cardiff he was driven to the airport by
best friend and fellow footballer Nicola
pal WA arriving at nan Atlantic just
before sunset at the other end coloured
IFS player liaison officer Callum Davis
was waiting to welcome the football out
back to the city while back in Argentina
Salle's mum was sat by the phone waiting
for it to ring the football it would
usually contact her every single night
that call of course never arrived to his
friends on whatsapp Sala expressed
concerns about the state of the plane
muchachos I tell you I love younger
polishing is a topic I appear also
libertagia the pericardial goopy
molarity Chicago the single engine piper
malibu aircraft took off at 7:15 p.m.
and disappeared from radar an hour and
15 minutes later misgivings were
expressed almost immediately about pilot
david Ibbotson's decision to fly Sky
News has obtained a copy of the flight
plans submitted for the journey back to
Cardiff the flight was planned under
visual flight rules which means the
pilot needs to be able to see a certain
distance ahead at all times
aviation experts have told Sky News the
chances of doing this on the night of
the 21st of January and likely to have
been limited all said they would not
risk putting their own family on that
flight it was a risky flight to do
probably the slightly higher risk than
one would normally like to do certainly
I would not advise flying a private
pilot flying at night long sea crossings
in winter and low level and possibly in
cloud that is beyond what I would
consider to be a safe flight
Emiliano Zapata was retrieved from the
wreckage of the plane north of the
channel island of Guernsey three weeks
later those close to him agonized about
why he was on that particular plane
tranio que le hace todo sol de nies
mementos nene porradasa gary o morado a
conscious are un poco más tranquilo
tomar sa minuto de sangría
a momento que complicado complicado
porque cuando un Trapasso he is a la una
Mariposa while family and fans grieve
Nantes and Cardiff are already involved
in a bitter legal battle Cardiff manager
Neil Warnock and the club have made
attempts to distance themselves from the
agent William acai but Sky News has
learned the Mackay family handled
logistics for both sides organising and
paying for five flights connected with
this deal including two for Warnock
himself at home in progress o talk
turning to money so soon feels grossly
insensitive his funeral was held in the
building where he played basketball as a
boy his coffin surrounded by floral
wreaths here they crave answers awaiting
the preliminary report of the air
accident board expected next week it's
understood the investigators have been
told the name of mystery owners of the
plane which is registered offshore in
progress so people are working class but
most feet live comfortably the main
business here is agriculture the selling
of Sawyer and corn the seller family one
a few here who don't actually own land
but in emiliano they produced by far its
greatest export the reality that their
most famous son will never return hurts
but there is the hope that Emiliano is
death can at least bring some good
Alcala de parte de Toledo said I mean
the polar
repeat arm ala hele persona repeat all
the ritual food will attack Vinci Kokomo
caldera nosotros lip or pasado
cualquiera nosotros empezar walker food
Oleta yaha lucky
Cato Silva para para que no la sir
[Music]
while the people of Progresso mourn the
wrangling over money between Cardiff and
Nan could go on for months or even years
through the most appalling tragedy
perhaps we can learn something about the
ugly side of the game Emiliano Salah
loved